origination we are going to watch a
trailer for The Super Mario Brothers
movie it's me Gregorio Johnny Boy Mamma
Mia my mama's so excited everyone's
gonna be doing this for their intros so
we we gotta join in on the fun some some
weird bad Italian accent and hopefully
Chris Pratt's sounds better ladies and
gentlemen I'm excited to see what
illumination has to offer so if you can
please go ahead leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also want to thank
today's video sponsor sponsor that we
were more than excited to partner up
with especially because Universal the
copyright claim everything there are
guarantee is copyright claim we'll talk
more about them after the trailer and
that is for wondery re-watcher Buffy the
Vampire series yeah it was really really
glad to be working with him
all right let's get to it
[Music]
thank you
wow holy moly oh
wow
Mountain
behold the king of the Coopers
Wowzer it looks cool
3D
open the gates
not a bad voice Jack Black
to spot a taste
[Laughter]
you know I do not
wow holy crap
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
oh this is exciting
welcome to the Mushroom Kingdom Kingdom
what is this
okay
I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine come
on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
okay
[Music]
my man
hideout in the horror Mansion okay well
well John what did you think of our
first look ah I mean it was really fun
to see Bowser I'm a big fan of Bowser
himself plus Jack Black that's a match
made in heaven for me really like the
voice like the sense for the scope and
the video game intensity they're gonna
give us uh you know I got a couple more
thoughts too but you know decent start
yeah yeah
I mean
I liked it I didn't actually quite I
like quite a bit of it there's I don't
know I mean I think I need to you know
what while we re-watch this trailer
we'll have more clear thoughts in the
meantime or we're from our sponsor all
right guys so for today's sponsor now
something you know might not know about
the real rechecks it's that we're in a
position where we can actually turn down
brand deals when when we'd like but once
in a while one comes along where we're
like yes instantly yes we want to do it
we'll pay you to do it let us do it
please so this comes from the wondery
podcast Network and it's for their new
series The re-watcher Buffy the Vampire
Slayer now John he's a major fan of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer you've seen the
whole thing my fiance uh started
introducing me to Buffy I'm only on like
season five currently so I still got
like 18 more seasons left to go but once
I'm there I'm gonna be able to feel like
I accomplished something important in my
life absolutely but this new podcast
it's coming from these they have great
chemistry but I can't pronounce Elena's
last name Elena art and Ash Kelly such a
good those have like action heroes don't
they they're best known for their uh
true crime series morbid and now they're
stepping into the world of fiction so
with this one though Elena she's a big
Buffy fan where Ash has never seen Buffy
so you're gonna be getting these weekly
Recaps going over the episode going over
awards every once in a while you'll have
some special guests from the show
themselves however you got both
perspectives Super Fan vs newbies I
don't know you guys I like these weekly
recap podcasts that have been you know
springing up into the ether estimated
anything to do and I think Buffy the
Vampire Slayer is a wonderful one to do
so guys as stated here enter The Buffy
verse with Elena and Ash listen to The
re-watcher Buffy the Vampire Slayer on
Amazon music Apple podcast or listen
early and AD free by subscribing to
wondery plus and apple podcast or the
wondery app thank you for partnering
with us more than thrilled to shout this
one out all right listen I'm not gonna
try to act like I'm some big Mario
expert here okay because yes have I
played some Mario games of course I've
played Mario game from beginning to end
grew up on the Super Nintendo games
played them all and then of course you
know Mario 64 and then Sunshine I've
only dabbled in the other games posted
of course like super smash whatever a
whole bunch of other ones and like fully
aware of that and like the main basic
plots of like fighting Bowser usually
having a rescue Peach I understand all
that this movie has like a a big scope
it's got to accomplish I'm not exactly
sure what it is and I was like huh you
can't quite put my finger on the pulse
right now I wonder if it's just
skepticism to be honest just because of
the fact of video game movie and parts
where it seemed to like semi-clash for
me was when it felt like I wasn't
watching a Mario movie trailer but in a
an illumination trailer if that makes
sense those are the parts where I was
like huh even though I'm like but that
that style works so well though for a
Mario Brothers movie because it's
light-hearted fun it's goofy it's not ex
supposed to be super duper serious it's
supposed to have that like Family Fare
friendly Vibe so part of me wonders
which is my own skepticism getting in
the way because when I whenever we watch
this trailer I go no I mean it was a
perilous beginning I really loved the
Striking dark animation it was evoking
uh it looks beautiful feels like there's
gonna be a sense of wonder to it which
is what you gotta do so like I don't
really know what the problem is with the
trailer or something probably
problematic with me I guess now uh Chris
Pratt's voice though what is this place
uh I gotta hear more of it before I make
I gotta hear like scenes of how it
really works because I feel like that's
the main thing the critical ear is gonna
be on now they've like done some things
with his design it looks like Mario but
they've changed some few things with
this shape flat ass and you know so
there's some things that are not uh not
not up to what this Hardcore Mario fans
really want I'm not bothered by it
however I guess the voice was like it
was gonna go like you worker Plum or
we're gonna go super retaliant when I
heard it I was like oh it actually just
sounds like a kind of a normal guy yeah
I was a little torn because I was like
this sounds like it's literally halfway
between a voice and just Chris Pratt's
voice so it's like splitting the
difference between what we were all
afraid of which was just like oh they're
just gonna make him Chris Pratt and yeah
we need to hear him in a full-on
dialogue scenario and I'm sure in the
full movie setting it'll be easier to
just kind of sink in and let it breathe
into what it is but at the same time I
was a bit like okay New Yorker still
hear a lot of Chris Pratt in there
sounds kind of like a voice but not a
hundred percent like a full character
and as to the you know missing je ne
sais quoi whatever it is like I wonder
if it's a sort of kineticism like I
thought it has an illumination movie
feel but I almost feel like a Mario
movie would require almost some kind of
Lego movie-esque sense of kinetic mad
calfness whereas this doesn't quite feel
like a video game maybe I don't know
though it's just a teaser and it's you
know just feels like a movie though I
don't know though yeah it's weird it's
like there's so much here that is
beautiful and that is kind of everything
you'd expect or want and at the same
time yeah I can't quite put my finger on
what is not quite nailing the you know
ah super excited anticipation for me
yeah I mean I fell off the minions
franchise what no when but it doesn't
exactly look like that I guess that's I
think I really think it's just my pre
for me I'm I am wondering if it's a lot
of it is that I'm projecting upon
viewing it that cynicism that I sort of
associate with
some of Illumination properties
sometimes they make some great stuff
away from movies are actually like the
actual despicable movies Despicable Me
movies are great I feel like it's easy
to dog them but yeah I mean I've liked a
lot of the illumination yeah exactly to
one degree or another yeah you could
just add that uh over saturation of
minions and it's also like super Mario's
like the such a prolific iconic
character game Etc that I think anything
and it's also got the live action movie
on its record for people to point at so
I think anything short of greatness is
gonna you know rile people up a little
bit simultaneously though you do have
the creators of the the actual video
game it seemed like very this is
presented at Nintendo Direct so they're
very much involved with this and they've
been you know really postponing and
letting anyone do any movies for a long
time so I feel like for them to have got
this going they would want to make sure
they're getting it right sure so perhaps
it is going to be you know
absolutely perfect we'll see how it goes
wait till it comes out I'm sure it's
gonna be a fine fun family right because
I don't know what I mean
I really don't know what's wrong with me
right now I'm like I feel like you know
most of the time just like yeah it'll be
a fun family film [ __ ] I'm just oh hey
they got Luigi's Mansion Vibes in there
and that's all I need boy yeah that's
that's my jams all right guys well what
did you think about the trailer leave
your thoughts down below thank you to
wonderly for sponsoring this video I'll
talk with y'all soon